Dire que je suis fou de toi ne rend
pas justice à mes sentiments
Je t'adore  obtenir la
bénédiction de son père mais non ce n'est pas un père monsieur
frère hé descends garçon tu as deux
secondes et balle de ferme tu es blanc
tu es blanc tu ne te bats pas c'est ce
petit clown sort avec ma soeur
oh mec Schtroumpf peut-être que tu es juste  veut dans
la famille je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il
veut d'
accord assez de ce méchant
oh ouais ne touchez aucun avantage laissez-vous me l'
apporter
vous les gars pensez que vous êtes dur parce que vous êtes le
petit gang dont je suis la définition  des
coups durs loin tu as sacrément raison de te
mettre au sol mec tu dois te
moquer de moi
tu vas sortir une arme regardes-
tu ça sortir bébé je ne savais pas comment aurais-je
su c'est une telle différence de hauteur
merci je  je suis un pourboire tu as 101 je t'ai eu
en une seconde